[Music]
california recall candidate larry elder
calling out the left's double standard
after an angry crowd of violent
protesters including an apparently
deranged woman wearing a gorilla mask of
all things threw an egg that nearly hit
the candidate
egg from behind
[Music]
so far there's been little outrage from
the left and the mainstream media is
being accused of downplaying what
happened with headlines that minimize
the violence and make little mention of
what seems to me at least the racist
nature of the incident isn't that the
headline the racist nature of the
incident larry elder terrying into the
silence
the l.a county sheriff alex villanueva
said that it was a hate crime and you
know if i had been a democrat can you
imagine what would have happened it
would have been talked about in
bangladesh they would have called it an
example of systemic racism but because i
have an r at the end of my name the
story did not get nearly the kind of
coverage i think it otherwise would have
gotten so what do you think of that
tyrus they are so quick to call anything
racist and he is a clearly racist crazy
lady well
that's where with you know how much i
respect you and i disagree don't call
her deranged don't call her crazy don't
give her that out she knew exactly what
she was doing one thing she didn't do
was practice throwing things with the
mask on okay that was the only thing
that she didn't that's the only thing
she didn't do bottom line this was 100
racist it was a hate crime but because
the left has pitched him as an uncle tom
you know any anyone who wants small
government and fiscal responsibility
can't possibly be black and this is what
a lot of brothers and sisters out there
i'm always like democrats only want to
support you
when you're with them it's not racist
when you're against them it's it's
literally
laughable
we don't know who this person's name is
if that would have been during the
previous administration all his
questions after that speech he gave
yesterday would have been his thoughts
on what happened there and how did he
condemn this attack but they don't
because it's not important there was one
on cnn where literally it was dismissed
in other news like this is what happens
they're not really concerned with racism
unless it's used to support what's going
on there you don't have to like larry
i'm not a big fan he talks too fast for
me i'm just being real i'm a former
california i wouldn't vote for that i
like caitlyn jenner's policies better
but he has every right to run he has
every right to say with his speak is
mine and he shouldn't be attacked like
that i like larry and in fact if he
beats gavin newsom gavin newsom could
take over the relief factor commercials
oh i'm going for that
yeah i'm sorry after wrestling
the polls though seriously dana look
like uh gavin newsom is going to walk
well yeah i mean recalls are very
difficult um and i think that gavin
newsom is if he does win um
he comes out stronger and the democrats
need a new generation of leaders and i
think he would be in a pretty strong
position as the governor of california
to be able to do that i do would point
out that during this campaign governor
newsom has spent a lot of time saying
that larry elder is a black white
supremacist and i think the question
should be asked to him like do you think
that's okay
and just saying things like that about
opponents no matter if they're black
white doesn't matter republican democrat
it's wrong and
leaders need to be the role models and
in this case that didn't happen
do you think katie that
too much was made of newsome's peril
that he it was never that close
well i think it's really important to
pay attention to the reason why he's
being recalled and if you look at the
data i mean democrats are registered two
to one
in you know against republicans in
california so it's just a tough uphill
battle but the idea that this many
people in california got organized and
were successful in even getting enough
signatures for a recall petition is a
success in itself in a place where
democrats outnumber republicans but i do
want to talk about this incident
um it's amazing to watch how much media
oxygen was given to jesse smallett when
he made up a hate crime uh bubba wallace
when he had a pulley in his in his
garage how much the fbi investigated
that you know nick sandman's life was
destroyed for a very long time by the
media
they accused him of of racism and he
wasn't engaged in racism and now you
have silence from the media and in fact
the media in california the la times
when they wrote that headline saying
that larry elder left a homeless
encampment after an incident they used a
photo of larry elder making it look like
he hit a woman like it they implied in
the photo that he was the reason why he
had to leave the homeless encampment not
that he got attacked so the double
standard is there but the good news is
larry elder has been fighting against
this his entire life which is why he was
ready to run for governor of california
what do you like about caitlyn jenner
more than
larry elder i never said that
i would agree that he does talk quickly
and uh but that's not what i based my
vote on i based it on looks
[Laughter]
you were essentially in the green room
geraldo you thought the gorilla masked
person third like a girl i think that
was sexist for you to say i say she you
know more throws like a liberal she
threw like catchy she throws like she
she actually throws better than falco
that's true but
notice this has not been covered on cnn
as of yesterday washington post never
picked this up newsome has not even
condemned it
kamala harris has she said anything
water's world geraldo asked for
statements of condemnation from all
these players and we've heard crickets
but if this had happened to maxine
waters one t no relation this would have
been everywhere as he said it would have
been in bangladesh and this is how you
rig an election in california geraldo
recall this is how you rig an election
recall elections report
negative stuff that comes from the
left-wing precincts like this and at the
same time you just slander the
republican opposition with racial
attacks black white supremacists what
does that even mean i'm kidding i i've
got to write down
yeah right a little diagram but you're
right it is it is all uh you know our
our our cubbies it's our whatever team
you're on
do anything you can
regardless of uh you know
morality as long as it suits your team
i'm really sick of politics and recall
elections are dumb just don't
ahead as america vows never to forget
we'll take you inside the hunt to kill
osama bin laden there are new details
you might not have heard about hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else